اكسنت كويشن
على علامه التوثيق في تويتر وكسب الاموال
من المستخدمين انقلب راسا على عقب سيلون
من الحسابات المزيفه منتحله اسماء الشركات
التجاريه كبرى اجتاحتر وتسبب بفوض عارمه
في المنصه الامثله كثيره حساب موثق في
تويتر لاسم شركه قليل الامريكيه للادويه
بتغريده تفيد بان الانسولين اصبح مجانا
الان التغريده هذه كلفت الشركه اكثر من 15
مليار دولار
وتراجع اسهميها بشكل حاد حساب مزيف للسبيس
اكس المملوكي من ماسك نفسه غرد عن عقودها
الحكوميه المربحه بينما حساب مزيف لتسلى
غرد بدعم اوكرانيا عسكريا بعشره الاف
السياره وان سيارتي تسلا هي الاكثر تطورا
وقابله للانفجار
حسابات مزيفه اخرى انتشرت بشكل كبير على
سبيل المثال للحصر
كواحده باسم ابل غردت بمحاوله بيع الهواء
بالمعنى الحرفي واخرى لشركه بيبسي مغرده
ان كوكاكولا افضل منها بينما غرد منتحل
لشركه كوكاكولا ان الشركه هي الاولى في
التلوث الناتج عن البلاستيك لاربع سنوات
على التوالي
الحسابات المزيفه الموثقه طالت شخصيات
سياسيه كذلك
ترامب بتغريدات تقول ان الجو بايدن هو رجل
وزعم جيد وتغريده اخرى تفيد بان اوباما
كان افضل رئيس للولايات المتحده وتغريده
ثالثه لتحمله المسؤوليه لاحداث السادس من
يناير اي اعمل شغب الكبتل ثمانيه دولارات
فقط هي ثمنه توفيقي اي حساب على تويتر دون
التحقق من الهويه مبلغ زهيد ولكن سيتسبب
بالفوضى لمنصه تعاني اساسا من الفوضى رشا
خياط العربيه